What are your thoughts on students taking Adderall?
Are there any long term effects?
There are long term studies of the utility of Adderall for attention deficit
disorder,
hyperactivity,
and the results are basically negative.
There is no evidence that the medications help with academic performance over
the long run.
I think that,
um,
Adderall is an amphetamine.
It is addictive.
It can sensitize you to other dopamine agonists.
So I would generally say it's something to be avoided.
You also want to really watch it in combination with marijuana,
for example,
or psychedelics because you can get unlucky and trigger a psychotic episode.
And that is not a good thing because once you have one psychotic episode,
you're a bit on the broken side and it's hard to put yourself back to the other.
So I would say use it sparingly,
if at all.
It's not,
it's not a good plan.
And especially not something good to be doing habitually.